[Music]
hello I'm Paul Rashidi with the Google
cloud platform team
now the compute engine
to use I thought it would be fun to do a
demo of using compute engine to set up a
cloud-based web server that way you can
see the process and then try it out for
yourself let's get started by pointing a
browser to cloud google.com slash
console when you first come to the cloud
platform you'll be prompted to create a
new project we're creating a test web
server so we'll call it web server
project well change the suggested
project ID as well and then click create
that will start the creation process now
that the product is being created we
will have access to all Google cloud
platform services
compute engine is a paid service so the
first thing we'll need to do is set up
our billing information you'll likely be
surprised at how affordable
experimenting with compute engine can be
I'm going to go ahead and fill out the
billing details and be right back
after we've entered our billing
information will navigate to the compute
engine instances page or will see a list
of the virtual machines that we've
created we don't currently have any so
let's add one we're going to create an
instance called test web server start by
clicking the new instance button at the
top of the page well specify the name is
test web server
for the zone will create our instance in
US central 1a for the machine type since
this is a test we'll select the smallest
one available the f1 micro with one
virtual CPU and just over a half a
gigabyte of RAM we'll go with the
suggested default image which is Debian
all of their settings should be OK for
our purposes now we can click the Create
button to create the virtual machine
our instance is almost ready so final
health checks are being run which is the
last step before the server's ready to
use
they're now our instance has been
created by default Google compute engine
blocks all connections to an instance
from the internet since we want to serve
web pages with our instance we'll need
to set up a firewall to specify that
incoming HTTP traffic is allowed on the
network where our newly created virtual
machine resides we can do that by
clicking networks select the default
network which is what we attach to our
virtual machine
click the Create new link that appears
at the top of the firewall section name
the firewall HTTP 1 and then in the
protocol ports field enter TCP 80 click
the create button to complete the
creation of the firewall once this
process is complete we should see the
new firewall appear in the firewalls
list
and there it is
in order to make changes like installing
software on our compute engine virtual
machine we need to remotely access the
machine the Google compute engine team
has created a great tool for doing this
called gcutil which is included in the
Google Cloud SDK the instructions for
downloading and installing gcutil can be
found at developers.google.com/live
slash sdk you'll essentially download a
zip file extract it and run an install
script then run an authentication script
and grant the tool access I'll go ahead
and speed through that process now
you
the authentication command here is will
grants the SDK access to work with your
project and oh I'll to token is being
issued and stored to this process
you
we're now set up to use gcutil
once you've installed gcutil on our
machine we can use it to remotely access
the instance we created there's a quick
way to do that if you go to the instance
details page on the side there there's
an SSH link copy the SSH command that's
provided there open a terminal window
and paste the SSH command in to run it
if you're prompted for a password and or
something you can remember for your SSH
keys the very first time you use a key
with the project it will take a few
minutes to upload the key
and there we go we've remotely accessed
our test web server and here we are on
the command line
well let's install some software
specifically some web server software
the web server we're going to install is
Apache a standard command used on Linux
install software's apt-get so we're
going to type sudo to run the command as
the superuser
apt-get install apache to
it's going to ask us to confirm we
to install it hit Y and type enter
the installation process has started
and now Patchi has been installed as
part of the installation process Apache
creates a default web page so let's jump
back to a browser to test if we can load
the default web page that Apache has
created now to find our default page so
that we can try to load it in the
browser we need to know the Internet
address of our test web server we can
find that back on the VM instances page
locate the external IP and copy it open
a new tab in your browser and paste it
in and there we go the default Apache
web page
rate our test web server is serving up
pages now to prove that this is our web
server let's modify the default web page
we'll jump back over to our terminal
window and type the following command to
open our default web page in a text
editor
we'll start by typing sudo to run the
command a super user then Nano which is
the text editor we'll use and then the
location of the Apache default web page
which is VAR w w index.html when we run
that it opens the index.html file in the
Nano text editor first we'll remove the
default text that's there and then we
can paste in an image so we can easily
tell that the page has been modified
well save the file with command o and
hit enter and then command X to exit
back in the browser we should be able to
refresh the page and there's our custom
default web page now I would call this
test a success
the final thing we need to do to wrap up
our test is to delete the virtual
machine we created and the persistent
disk as I do this let's make a
calculation about how much this whole
test cost
first to perform the delete will select
our test web server VM
then scroll down and click the delete
this instance button well check the
option for deleting the boot disc that
was created with our VM and then click
OK
the deletion process has started
regarding the cost the current virtual
machine price for the type we used is
1.9 cents per hour we ran our server for
around 10 minutes so our virtual machine
usage cost comes in at just under a
third of a cent
and there we go the virtual machine has
been deleted the persistent disk pricing
is four cents per gigabyte per month so
that roughly comes to just under half a
cent for 500 gigabyte boot disk the
suggested so everything we did on
compute engine we did for less than one
cent thanks for watching now it's your
turn go try creating your own
cloud-based web server on compute engine